NARRATOR: Welcome to Academy
Dialogues, It Starts With Us.
A safe space for
honest conversation
and authentic thoughts.
Our conversation today
is owning your brand.
Guiding this conversation
is Academy governor,
award-winning film and TV
producer, best-selling author
Devon Franklin.
Joining Devon, producer
Debra Martin Chase.
Film producer,
digital publisher,
and creator of the Hollywood
black list, Franklin Leonard.
President and managing
partner of M88, Phil Sun.
On to you, Devon.
DEVON FRANKLIN: Hey
hey, what's up y'all?
Thank you for being here.
This is another addition
of Academy Dialogues.
As an Academy
governor, we are so
excited to be a
part of this series.
It's really about bringing
conversations to the forefront
that we traditionally
don't have.
It's all about representation.
It's all about inclusion.
And one of the ways to get
there is to talk and communicate
about uncomfortable truths.
To talk about where
we are and where
we need to go as an industry.
So I just want to say what's up.
Welcome.
Debra and Phil and
Franklin, what's up man?
How y'all doing today?
Debra, you're on mute.
We've got to unmute.
We've got to unmute--
DEBRA MARTIN CHASE:
We've got to unmute.
Good to see you guys.
DEVON FRANKLIN: Good to--
FRANKLIN LEONARD:
We've got to unmute.
We should just put that
on a t-shirt, right there.
I feel like that's a mantra--
DEBRA MARTIN CHASE:
The daily conversation.
FRANKLIN LEONARD:
--for going forward.
PHILLIP SUN: Yeah, but some
people have got to mute though.
Some people have got to mute.
FRANKLIN LEONARD: That's
a very good point.
PHILLIP SUN: I'll go on
the other end of that.
DEBRA MARTIN CHASE: Thank
you Phil, thank you, Phil.
DEVON FRANKLIN: I love it.
I love it.
So even before we get started,
listen Franklin and Phil,
I just want to just note
that we, all three of us,
are grateful to share the
airspace with Debra Martin
Chase on this conversation.
I want to just note
that she is a legend.
She is a trailblazer.
If we could do half of what
she's done in this business,
we will have done a whole lot.
So, I'm just honored to
be here with all of you,
but specifically you Debra.
So thank you.
DEBRA MARTIN CHASE: Thank you.
DEVON FRANKLIN: So I just want
to jump in and really kind
of dive into what I feel is a
conversation that we have not
had and we are not having.
And I really want to
talk about finding
success outside of the
traditional Hollywood system.
All of us have done
that and are doing that.
So I really want to get
into the system itself.
Is the system working?
Is the system failing?
What are the changes that
can be made in the system?
Because we talk about this
institution of Hollywood,
but very few people
have had the inside look
into the system of Hollywood
like the four of us.
So Debra, why don't
we start with you.
obviously?
For those who may not know,
you are a Harvard Law graduate.
You are an attorney.
But you also took a
turn in your career,
where you became an intern
for the legendary Frank Price,
chairman of Columbia Pictures.
And so, you have an intimate
knowledge of the studio system,
but you chose to blaze trails as
a producer, a content creator.
So talk about your
experience inside the system
and what led you to
ultimately make the decision
to work outside of it.
DEBRA MARTIN CHASE: Two things.
One was that, having had
a career as an attorney,
that I put on the shelf to make
movies because I loved movies
and it was a passion and
it was a dream to do it.
Getting the glimpse
into the system
while I was working with Frank,
and he he's my first mentor.
He was so good to me and
gave me the opportunity
as his executive assistant.
It usually goes to the
white guy, frankly.
I went with him to his meetings.
I sat with him in the
office and asked questions.
And so I really got a
look at what was going on.
And I just found, at
least at that time,
the politics were so heavy.
It wasn't about-- he
was about filmmaking,
but in terms of the rank
and file, the executives,
it was really about positioning
and posturing and fear
and parking spaces.
And it really wasn't
about the work.
But secondly,
particularly once he left,
and he was kind of ousted
in a very big coup,
there was no place for me.
Like nobody wanted--
I used to say, I felt
like the lone Democrat
in the Republican White House.
As a black woman, nobody really
was interested in the things
that I was interested in doing.
And as will be a theme, I think,
throughout this conversation,
there is diversity, and
then there's inclusion.
And I was not being included.
They weren't inviting me
to the dinner parties.
They weren't building
relationships with me.
And I'm a very,
very social person.
I have friends all over the
world, from all walks of life,
colors, whatever.
And it just wasn't
a welcoming place.
And I'm like, I'm not
living my life like this.
I mean, I want to make
movies, but I also
want to be appreciated
for who I am.
DEVON FRANKLIN: Yeah, wow.
We're going to unpack the
diversity versus inclusion,
because you are 1,000% right.
And I think that's
maybe one of the reasons
why, as people of
color, there has always
been a challenge within
the Hollywood system.
Because of that word
diversity, which
is so different than the
idea behind inclusion.
So Franklin, I want
to toss to you.
Debra mentions politics.
You were a studio
executive for Universal.
Talk about the politics.
Talk about the studio system
and what you saw there,
or what your experience was
that made you feel, or made
you decide, you know what?
This is maybe not
the life for me,
and there's something different.
FRANKLIN LEONARD: Yeah I
think like Debra mentioned,
I came into the industry
I think somewhat naive.
I wanted to make movies.
I wanted to make great movies.
And I wanted those
movies to make money.
And those were my
priorities as I
thought through the
material that came in.
I would look at the culture.
I would look at
audiences, and I would
try to identify material
that might work with those.
And whenever I would bring
material the conversation,
or perspective to
the conversation,
I realized that the
responses weren't
driven by of rational
analysis of the argument
that I was trying to make.
It was driven by, OK how does
this response position me
vis-a-vis other people at the
company that will allow me
to ascend to certain statures?
And I understand the
impulse behind that.
Right?
People have mortgages.
They have kids in
private school.
They have their own
career aspirations.
And they're trying
to secure the bag.
And that leads to certain
incentive structures
that lead to certain behavior.
I've just never
been good at that.
And I recognize it as something
that is, in some ways,
a professional failure of mine.
I'm just not good at navigating
corporate bureaucracy.
I am good at advocacy, and
I am good at identifying
good material and
getting it to the public.
And so, I realized very
early on that I was never
going to thrive in an
environment that was
driven by that system of rules.
And it became very
clear to me that if I
was going to be successful
in this industry,
or likely any other
frankly, I would have
to try to do it my own way.
And I left Universal to go to
Overbrook to work for Will.
Part of that exit was
them committing to me
that I could develop the black
list as a for-profit venture,
simultaneous to working there.
So I was working 9:00
AM to 9:00 PM for Will,
and then 9:00 PM to
2:00 AM for myself.
And two years later, I was
able to launch the company.
Literally almost
eight years ago today.
And I had that runway
because of the understanding
that I think Will and James
Lassiter had too, which is,
you can't do it alone.
And you need somebody
to say, OK look,
I don't know how this
is going to work.
But as long as you
do right by us,
we're going to make it possible
to you do right by you.
And everybody is
going to be good.
And I'm infinitely
thankful to them for that,
because they really
did set me on my way,
and here we are today.
DEVON FRANKLIN: Yeah, which is
great because, to that point,
having that type of
support and incubation
is a critical element
of, I believe,
anyone in this business
to be successful
has to have incubation.
Because this is an
apprenticeship business.
It's a very difficult
business just
to come into, without having
learned every aspect of it,
and having others who have
already learned it help us
along the way.
So listen, I share the same
level of great gratitude
for Will and James.
I got my start as an intern
for them, and all of that.
So without that
type of incubation,
certainly wouldn't
be here today.
So Phil, I want to talk and
just talk about this idea of you
just recently exited the system.
You were an agent.
One of the top agents for WME.
Representing some of the most
dynamic and successful talent
in the world.
But recently, the
news of your exit
to start the management division
for Macro shook the industry.
I personally was like, what?
Phil Sun is gone?
What is going on
with these places?
I'll be honest with you.
So, can we talk about what
was going on in the system?
What were the politics
or the challenges
that you may have
faced, that ultimately
may have led to making the
decision to go out on your own
and start this new
incredible endeavor?
PHILLIP SUN: Yeah,
it's been a journey
to where we got to with M88.
And it's certainly,
to your point
and also to Franklin's point,
my new venture is not alone.
Like Charles King, who
I partner with at Macro,
who has really built a pathway
for many people of color
outside of the system.
We stand on his
shoulders for sure,
as we build this new company.
But the system itself
and representation, it's
tricky, right?
Because in representation,
you need to learn the system.
In order to advocate
for stories of people
of color and advocate
for your clients fully,
you need to understand,
what is the strength
and how they have
done it in the past.
So my journey at the agency
was actually, for the 15 years
I was there from mailroom
to senior partner,
it was all a big
educational system for me.
Right?
And like you said,
you needed mentors
to kind of excel in this
business, and any sort
of system, and unfortunately--
I had a few great mentors,
Charles King being
one of them, Patrick Weitzel.
But you need that
continued growth
in order to continue to grow.
Right?
So the representation
system, if we're
talking for real, the
agencies and the old school
representation
systems, are built
to represent a certain
type of talent.
Right?
And it's built to operate in an
older system across the board
with studios,
producers, et cetera.
Right?
Like to what Debra
was talking about,
you can do business
people, but there's
a different thing where you're
going to dinners with them
and going on rafting trips and
having friendships with them.
Right?
I think the representation
game is evolving,
because now the clientele that
is being represented and also
making money at the box office
and putting butts in seats
and eyeballs on
television screens,
they don't look like
they did before.
They're multicultural.
They're the new global majority.
So now the system
is doing its best
to try to catch up to
having representatives
that also look like the
talent that is on screen.
And we're playing a
little bit from behind is,
that's not something you
can react to and fix.
That's a pipeline.
That's actually putting
efforts in years
prior to, like it took me 15
years to get to where I am.
And that's me, I'm unique.
And now I look down and see
the new future of the agency
where I left, it
gives me great joy
to see people who look like
me, look like the world looks.
But there's such
a long way to go.
And because the system is built
in a certain way, I felt that--
and also as you
know agency wars,
if you do something good
for diversity and inclusion
at one agency, you
hope it would spread.
But it can be taken as,
oh this is a WME thing,
or oh this is a CAA thing,
whether it's amplify,
whether it's power.
DEVON FRANKLIN: Right.
PHILLIP SUN: We kind of put a
ceiling on ourselves, as far as
how we can move.
And so all of that
to be said, it
led me to a decision
of partnering
with Charles King, who is
a longtime mentor of mine,
with the support of my agency.
And becoming a third party.
Becoming a manager.
Where we can push the envelope.
We're building a
representation firm now
that not only represents
the global majority,
but is built within from
the global majority.
The point of view of
diversity at agencies
is usually an afterthought,
it's a program.
It's a reaction to the times of
what's going on in the world.
This representation
firm is built
from the core of those
beliefs from the onset.
DEVON FRANKLIN: Mm.
PHILLIP SUN: There
is no afterthought.
There is no reaction.
It is just us.
And in a world that's chasing
culture, I think all of us
have seen the studios
and the buyers
chasing what is a culture,
who is a culture mover?
We're trying to bring culture
within one institution,
instead of having
everyone spread out.
We now have a home, if you
choose and want to come,
it's here for you.
And so it it's a complicated
world, the representation
world.
Because I think it's the least--
it's the silo of the industry
that's least spoken about.
Because there's always
a negative connotation
to reps, to suits, to whatever
label you want to put on it.
It's not often positive.
And we as a community
need to address
that as well, because
quite frankly,
the agencies, big
ones especially,
they're perfect
marketing machines.
They understand how
to make someone great.
But we have to understand how
to utilize that in our way,
how to work with them and push
them to market in our way.
And hopefully that's what
M88 will help specifically
the big agencies do.
DEVON FRANKLIN: Right, and for
those that are watching M88
is the new company,
the joint venture,
that Phil Sun has started
with Charles King and Macro.
I want to ask a potentially
provocative question
just to all of you.
Do they not like us?
When you talk about
all of us have--
I was, as you all may
know, I was an executive
at Columbia Pictures
for 10 years,
and worked my way up from
director of development
all the way to senior
vise president.
But going back to
Debra, there weren't
invitations to hang out
and do the social things
or be a part of the
social crowd, so to speak.
I was just working within
the system and doing my best.
But I just want to
ask that question.
Is it that they
just don't like us?
Is the system racist?
Is the system prejudiced?
Let's just ask the
honest question.
What is it?
So whoever wants to
just jump in on that.
DEBRA MARTIN CHASE:
I think it's twofold.
DEVON FRANKLIN: OK.
DEBRA MARTIN CHASE:
I think, one,
this is something that people
really don't talk about.
LA is one of the most racially
segregated cities in America.
The west side is
kind of all white.
The east side of town
is more integrated.
So as a practical
matter, and you know--
because I also live in
New York, pre-COVID,
everybody took the subway.
Everybody walked
down the street.
So just on a daily
basis, you would
interact with people that
didn't look like you.
And it's just a
different makeup.
So you have people that,
just in their real lives,
don't know any people of color.
Except for perhaps,
honestly, the nanny
or the gardener or somebody that
they do not consider an equal.
So there's not a comfort level.
There's this kind of
natural, OK, you're black,
I'm white, with people.
So, I think that that's one.
And then secondly, it
isn't until recently,
and we can all chart
how it happened,
that Hollywood finally
recognized that diversity
is good business.
For years, we were
saying, guys the world
does not look like the
west side of Los Angeles.
And they were still
saying, you know what,
but I don't know, a black
lead in an hour-long drama.
I don't know that white
people are going to tune in.
Because they weren't
talking to people
that didn't think like they did.
So, I think once Hollywood
realized-- so therefore,
there was no incentive to
reach out, to change lifestyle,
to expand your comfort
level, vision, whatever.
So Phil you were
kind of alluding
to this, once Hollywood
said, oh this is money.
These stars are money.
The Rock is the biggest star,
one of the biggest stars
is The Rock.
Vin Diesel.
You start going down the list
of sure enough moneymakers now,
most of them are--
So it changed.
It's like, OK well we
need to know people.
We need to begin to be
familiar with these people.
They need to like us,
because we need them.
And so it started to open
things up, but I still find--
because again, I spend a
lot of time in New York,
and I'm on the board of
the New York City Ballet,
and Second Stage Theater
and blah, blah, blah.
You know, when I walk
into a room there
and people don't know
me, they're like,
oh she's in the room,
she must be interesting.
Let me make a point
to get to know her.
Here, you go in a
room and they see
a black woman that's not
Beyonce or Halle or somebody
that people think,
oh, is important.
They assume you're
not important.
They assume they don't
need to know you.
And I can't tell you how many
times I've been in a room
and somebody will
overhear my name,
because we do so much on the
phone pre-COVID, presume.
And people say, oh my
god Debra, it's you.
I didn't recognize you.
And it's a whole
different attitude.
DEVON FRANKLIN: Wow.
DEBRA MARTIN CHASE: So, yeah.
DEVON FRANKLIN: Got it.
FRANKLIN LEONARD:
I would actually
challenge the idea that
people have figured out
that it's good business.
I think we're getting there.
I think they're starting
to realize that,
but I don't think
that they still think
of black actors, women,
black women, Latinx actors,
Asian actors, as
being financially
equivalent to their white
peers in pure economic terms.
And I say that for two reasons.
One, the economic argument
has always been there.
Eddie Murphy was
big in the '80s.
Denzel Washington
was big in the '90's.
Will Smith was big in the 2000s.
We have always been amongst the
biggest movie stars on earth,
even internationally.
And I remember going into
studio meetings and saying, hey,
why don't you make
more black movies?
And the answer was
always, well we'd love to,
but we can't sell those abroad.
People don't want to see
in black faces on screen.
And here's the thing, that
was and continues to be a lie.
That requires that you believe
that for all of the last 40
years, while hip hop was the
most powerful cultural force
around the world,
and people were
going to concerts
the world over,
while people were cheering
for black athletes,
while people were paying
to see Coming to America
in Germany in the mid 1980s,
somehow other black actors
weren't viable.
Which was not true, period.
And the numbers have
been run by Stacy Smith
at USC, that have proven
statistically that there
is no difference in
the international box
office of diverse content when
it is supported by marketing
dollars that the studios
traditionally have not spent.
PHILLIP SUN: That's right.
FRANKLIN LEONARD: And I
would say beyond that,
there is also a
gross undervaluation
of people not in
front of the camera.
When a young black woman
walks into an agent's office
and says, I'm a director, they
don't think to themselves,
I'm talking to the
next Steven Spielberg.
They don't think, I'm talking
to the next James Cameron.
And as a consequence of
that, when Ava DuVernay
wins the Best Director
Award at Sundance,
she gets no studio meetings
off the back of that.
None.
Not one.
And you can ask her
about that right.
Whereas, if you are
Colin Trevorrow,
and you win the Best
Director Award at Sundance
for Safety Not Guaranteed,
your next movie
is a Jurassic Park sequel.
And again, it comes from
a gross undervaluation
of people of color, of women,
of all of these things.
And the reality is we need to
put a very fine point on it.
That is racism.
That is sexism.
And it's perpetuated
by a system that
allows people to think
that they're justifying it
because they're saying, oh well,
if you look at the numbers,
these people have less value.
I challenge anybody
who makes that claim.
Show me the numbers.
Give me your receipts.
I'll become your best advocate.
I've been saying
this for 15 years,
and no one has
presented those numbers.
DEBRA MARTIN CHASE: But
let me say one thing,
and Phil I know you
want to jump in.
PHILLIP SUN: No, go ahead.
DEBRA MARTIN CHASE: What
happened with Eddie, Denzel,
and Will, people said,
well they're white.
I mean they're black, but people
don't think of them as black.
So they took them
out of the equation.
FRANKLIN LEONARD: Exactly.
DEBRA MARTIN CHASE: Right?
Which that's what racism does.
It's like you can't see
the truth for the truth.
PHILLIP SUN: Well when
you can't beat it,
you try to embrace it, right?
Also, here's what ultimately
this all comes down to.
Your question was, in
my personal opinion,
I don't think the industry
is inherently racist.
I think it's, as I've said
before, older systems.
But here's the deal.
All these decisions,
all of these movies
that are being
made, content being
made, people being elevated.
It all comes down to who
is present in the smallest
of rooms of decision makers.
Until that changes,
you're lacking
a point of view, when the
smallest room is created, when
the decisions are made
to fight for the things
that we all as a
collective already know.
Is that when Moonlight
is successful.
When Black Panther
When Crazy Rich
Asians is successful.
When Tigertail
gets rave reviews.
It's not a surprise.
It works.
It has worked over and over,
but because it's so spaced out,
because there are still
barriers to entry,
everything seems
like an anomaly.
You don't see that with
traditionally white content,
because it's so overwhelming.
It's normal.
If you normalize, then
maybe these arguments
that are foolish stop.
But it all goes to the top.
When there are people of
color or allies or women
up top making decisions, there
will be different results.
DEVON FRANKLIN: Good.
Excellent points.
Debra what you were
just saying, it
reminded me of that iconic
scene in Do The Right Thing
when Mookie's having the
conversation at the pizza shop.
And there's some black
faces, and they're like,
oh no, those aren't niggas.
You know what I mean?
Like no.
And it's this idea that just
because a person of color,
a black man, black woman,
so on and so forth,
becomes successful
at that level,
oh they've transcended race.
It is the most
fundamental lie that
is perpetuated in our business.
And then, Franklin, I
want to touch on something
you said, which
was very profound.
Listen, I know y'all
know me as a preacher.
I don't know.
Franklin, man, you got
a preacher in you man.
You're quite an
evangelist my brother.
FRANKLIN LEONARD:
It's the name, it
comes from the Franklin thing.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
DEVON FRANKLIN: That's
right, that's it.
Because what you said, which is
so true, is this idea of value.
Just because the color
of our skin is different,
does that mean we
are less valuable?
And when you think
about how Hollywood
has perpetuated that
lie, that goes back
to the days of slavery.
When we as black people weren't
even considered a full person.
So this is why we have to
continue to literally have
this conversation, so that the
power structure and those that
are in position can hear this.
And when you really
hear it played back,
it sounds ludicrous.
Well no, of course, just because
you have a different color,
or you're a different gender,
doesn't make you less valuable.
But when you run
the P&L, when you
talk about who you can
put movies together with,
their answer is, oh
well they don't travel.
Well, why don't they travel?
Because they aren't
supported, they
aren't given the opportunity.
FRANKLIN LEONARD: Because
you never marketed them.
DEBRA MARTIN CHASE: Exactly.
Beyonce is the biggest
music star in the world.
FRANKLIN LEONARD: On earth.
DEBRA MARTIN CHASE: On earth.
And I remember being in
Kathmandu, Nepal, years ago
and watching this kid
walk down the street
with his pants hanging down.
He had an old boom
box playing hip hop.
And I'm like, we drive
culture around the world.
How are movies not
being received?
PHILLIP SUN: And also--
go ahead.
FRANKLIN LEONARD: I was just
going to say two things.
There two moments for me
that really crystallized
where Hollywood
misses it on race,
and particularly as it
applies to black folks.
One was actually relatively
early in my career.
I remember, I think it
might have been Ride Along,
and every Friday night
before the movies come out.
And there are all of these
organizations that will
try to forecast the box office.
And they forecasted the
box office for Ride Along.
The predictions were somewhere
in the low 20s, I think,
or high teens.
I remember tweeting,
it's a black movie.
Take the over.
Always take the over
on black movies,
because they will
always underestimate us.
And sure enough,
the movie came out,
I think Ride Along opened
like mid 30s or something.
And one of those
organizations tweeted,
who could have foreseen
that Ride Along
was going to do so well?
And I responded.
I was like, well here's
my receipt that I did.
I always said take the over.
And I was like,
and by the way, you
should know that
if you look back
at your last 10
black movies, you've
been under every single time.
And that may say something.
And their response
was, well why do you
have to make it about race?
And I was like, listen,
it is about race, one.
That's why I made it about race.
But two, I'm actually less
offended as a black man
than I am as a math nerd,
because your model is
clearly wrong.
And if you underestimate
something consistently,
you should probably
fix your model.
Now that's sort of fun from
a math nerd gotcha thing.
But it goes to the core
of another issue, which
is the studios themselves
are using the same formulas
and algorithms to predict the
box office when they greenlight
those movies.
And if they assume
that they're going
to make less money
than they are,
they're less likely
to make those movies.
They're less likely to give
them the financial support
from a budget perspective and
from a marketing perspective.
And you end up with
a circular process
that results in less success.
And it is remarkable and
a testament to the work
that black folks and frankly
all kinds of diverse folks
in this business are
doing, whether they
be gay, whether they be
Asian, whether they be Latinx.
That they continue
to over-perform,
despite the lack of resources.
It goes to show just
how much talent is there
and just how much money there
is being left on the table
by not giving them the
budgets they deserve
and not giving them the
marketing support they deserve.
Very quickly, the
second thing was,
I was in Shanghai two years ago.
And I think we all know that one
of the reasons that Hollywood
specifically gives about racism
and black folks on screen
is, well, we'd love to
make more black movies,
but it's really hard to
sell those movies in China
specifically.
And it's a huge market
and it's really important
that we are successful there.
I was walking back to my
hotel one night in Shanghai,
and a giant billboard above
the Tomorrow Square Marriott
was a billboard for
the new Apple iPhone
with a dark-skinned black
woman on the Billboard.
Now Apple clearly thinks they
can sell iPhones in China
with black faces.
And somehow Hollywood
doesn't think they
can sell black faces in movies.
If I had to choose
between who's done
a more consistent job of selling
their products effectively
around the world, I'm
picking Apple every time.
And the core of that is,
it's not just racist to say,
oh we can't sell
black people abroad.
It's specifically saying, no we
can't sell black people abroad,
because the Chinese are
more racist than we are.
It's actually a double racism,
because you're characterizing
not only black folks and
their value around the world,
but also Chinese people
and the Chinese community,
as somehow worse
than the Westerners
that created anti-blackness
in the first place.
PHILLIP SUN: Yeah
it's deflecting.
It's absolutely deflecting.
FRANKLIN LEONARD: Yeah.
Which is why, for me, all of
us have got to get together,
because if all of us
aren't at the party,
it's not a good party.
I'm interested in a culture
that has everybody represented.
I want the Asian
community there.
I want the black
I want the Latinx
community there.
I want the LGBTQ
I want the Middle
Eastern community there.
I want women there.
The food's going to be better.
Music's going to be better.
The dance floor is
going to be lit,
and we're all going
to have a great time.
DEBRA MARTIN CHASE: It's
the world we live in.
PHILLIP SUN: Absolutely.
DEBRA MARTIN CHASE:
Listen, we love
movies, that's why we're
here and we work so hard.
But the movies are
to represent what's
going on in society, in
the world at a given time.
And if we're not capturing
the globalization,
the multicultural thing
that's going on right now,
then we're dis-serving
the art of cinema.
It's interesting.
TV has had a
different trajectory.
And in some ways, TV has kind
of led this current phase--
and I don't think it's a
phase, I think it's a turn--
to embrace diversity.
And Phil you made
the point of it
goes with the decision-makers.
Well, there was a
moment in time that
really didn't get
publicized much,
where the head of drama at
every major network was black.
You know it was Channing.
It was Terence Carter.
It was my girl Pearlena.
And that's when Scandal--
they didn't want to cast black.
But you had Shonda coming off of
Grey's Anatomy with some juice.
You had Channing
as head of drama.
And you had the fact that
the character was based
on Judy Smith, a black woman.
So people knew
that they would get
killed if they cast her white.
So it was with trepidation
that the decision was
made to cast Kerry Washington.
And you know, boom.
Then Viola, boom.
And then Lee Daniels with
Empire took it over the top.
The highest-rated debut in
a decade, blah, blah, blah.
And that helped the rest of the
industry say, oh wait a minute.
PHILLIP SUN: I
think that's right.
I think also on top
of all of that right,
going back to what Franklin said
before about traveling abroad,
and it works if you
market it correctly.
I think that not
only decision-making
processes of content,
but marketing dollars,
and who's marketing.
Who's making decisions
on marketing?
We're seeing such a trend now
of black artists, Asian artists,
whomever, whatever talent,
multicultural talent,
having their own
marketing firms.
It's because they're not being
listened to at the studio
level.
They only know how to market
the way that they traditionally
have marketed, and that's
not speaking to the audience
that the artist is actually
trying to speak to,
and it's not speaking
to the audience
in the way the content is
trying to speak to them.
And so you can't market
Ride Along necessarily
with a white lens, and expect
it to land in the community.
That doesn't work.
It sets it up for failure.
All these pieces that are again
in a perfectly formed machine,
just need to evolve to
be used in the way that
reflects the world today.
And it will work.
But until we make those
decision-makers reflect
more of what the
world looks like,
we're going to be at a deficit.
DEVON FRANKLIN: So speaking of--
oh go ahead Frank.
FRANKLIN LEONARD: I
was just going to say,
one thing that does
excite me about that film,
is that at the end
of the day, given
the way the world is working
and given technology,
and one upside of the
pandemic, to the extent
that we can talk about
that, is that because
of the rapid change, those folks
who do lead those companies who
fail to understand
where things are going,
they have really two options.
One is to do nothing.
Continue to do what they
do and run their companies
into the ground.
Or find somebody
who does understand
the culture as it
exists now, and then
have a chance of success.
And so in many ways,
it is the shareholders.
It is the boards of
these companies who
need to look around at
the people who are running
these things and say,
is this the best person
to take us through this moment?
And if they're not, you
have a fiduciary obligation
to your company and
to your shareholders
to remove them and replace
them with someone who does.
And that's just the way it is.
PHILLIP SUN: Could I piggyback
on that for a second?
FRANKLIN LEONARD: Of course.
PHILLIP SUN: That's
absolutely right,
and I also want to turn it on
us a little bit as a community.
When those executives or our
friends get those positions,
we have to back them
as a unified group.
There is not one seat
at the table anymore.
Build your own table.
They will come.
Trust me, it's cooler there.
It's just the culture is there.
We have to have that
together mentality,
because the truth is,
any cultural group is not
strong enough to stand
up to the majority.
Singular group.
They're just not.
The whole reason I
paired up with Charles,
other than he's my mentor, is
time to send a message, too.
It's like, yes.
I had opportunities elsewhere
to be probably, ultimately
the token.
Or I can link arms
with my mentor
and be stronger together.
To stand on the shoulders
of what he's already built,
and to continue to rise
and pull everyone with us.
I think one of the coolest
things, Theresa Kang
and myself, we represented
Lena Waithe together
when we were at WME.
And we brought her to Crazy
Rich Asians, and she she
posted about Crazy Rich Asians.
And at the time,
the Asian community
was like, wow, thanks.
Oh, that's incredible.
But on the flip
side, there's also
some community
members who were like,
why are you supporting them?
They don't support us.
We have to build that bridge.
DEBRA MARTIN CHASE: Absolutely.
PHILLIP SUN: Because
if I'm standing
by Deb, Devon,
and Franklin, they
can't say it's a Chinese thing.
They can't pigeonhole me.
And if anyone's standing
by Deb, of us three,
they can't just say it's
a powerful woman thing.
Because I'm there.
FRANKLIN LEONARD: That's right.
PHILLIP SUN: You're there.
You've got to play a little
bit of offense through defense.
Where are they going
to poke the holes?
Cover up.
DEBRA MARTIN CHASE:
Well it's the oldest--
look, I don't want
to get into politics,
but divide and conquer
is one of the oldest
strategies in the book.
And we've got to take control.
You're absolutely right Phil.
DEVON FRANKLIN: 1,000%.
On that part,
we're acknowledging
the challenges in the
industry and the truth
of the industry in
a way that I believe
anyone watching
this conversation
will be riveted by it, and
their mind will be expanded.
And I think it will also
produce, I'm hoping,
more of a desire
to create change.
I want to talk about
something which
we don't talk about a lot.
But I know that each one of
us has had to deal with it.
Frustration.
When we acknowledge the
reality of the systems
that we all have to deal with in
order to further our business,
live our dreams.
I just want each one of
you just to take a moment.
How do you deal
with frustration?
How do you not just say,
forget it, I'm done?
I can't do it anymore.
I'm tired.
How do you handle frustration?
Franklin, I want to start with
you, and then we'll go to Deb,
and then we'll go to Phil.
FRANKLIN LEONARD: Most recently
I've been running a lot.
I find it very difficult
to focus on my frustrations
when I'm struggling to breathe,
so that's very helpful.
PHILLIP SUN: You
look very slender.
FRANKLIN LEONARD: The pandemic's
been good for me in that regard
too.
Look, I think for
me, it comes down
to remembering how lucky I am
that these are my frustrations.
And that there are folks who--
my grandfather never
finished the fifth grade
in west central Georgia.
His father was born a slave
And so when I think
about the frustrations
that I have trying to
navigate the film business,
knowing that I have
a roof over my head
and I can afford a nice meal,
it becomes a lot more difficult
for me to be overcome by the
frustrations that I have.
Because I can look in
the mirror and say,
yeah this is really frustrating,
and it is really difficult.
But people that
have come before me
have dealt with worse, under
more adverse circumstances.
And I will be
damned if I let less
than they had to endure
prevent me from trying
to accomplish what they did.
Because I'm already
standing on their shoulders,
I can at least match their work.
And it helps.
It doesn't remove
the frustration,
but it definitely increases
my capacity to deal with it.
And I think it's
a debt that I owe
everyone that came before me
to try to endure and find ways
to cope.
But I also think it's
really important,
and this is a self care thing.
I made a joke about the
running, but it's true.
Sometimes you just have
to pull the thing out
of the socket for a minute.
Go for a run.
Eat some unhealthy food.
Watch an old Richard
Pryor special.
And just allow your brain to not
feel the anxiety and the stress
and the frustration.
Get a good night's sleep,
and wake up the next morning
ready to fight again.
Because you can't win every
day, you don't win every game.
Like if I played
any sport, they're
are going to be days when
you get taken to town,
and you go back to
the locker room.
And you're like, man forget it.
I shouldn't even be
playing this game.
But there's another game on
the schedule, and you wake up
and you keep playing
the schedule.
And the hope is that you
win more than you lose.
And you make the playoffs,
and you have a chance
to take it to game seven.
And it's a cliche metaphor,
but I think it's really true.
You can't take
yourself too seriously,
and you can't think that
anything is apocalyptic.
Because for all the
seriousness of the work
that we do, and it
is serious, it's
not life or death
in the short term.
And so if you can take a look
at a long enough timeline,
we all should be able to win.
And I call Phil.
I email you Devon.
I run into Deb, and you
tell me it's going to be OK.
And that makes it easier.
DEVON FRANKLIN: Love that.
Debra?
DEBRA MARTIN CHASE: You
know, when I was growing up,
I never saw people on
screen that looked like me.
And I was a kid that grew
up with film and television.
My dad was a huge movie buff.
And so I got into this
business to change that.
To change the images on screen.
To change the
narrative, if you will,
about women and women of
color and people of color.
So I had a higher mission.
I also was a lawyer.
I practiced law.
So I wasn't defined
by the business.
And so, I realized that I
just kept moving forward.
I would deflect
things that happened.
I'm on a mission.
That's your problem.
I was back in the
days when literally, I
would walk in to a
meeting, and the guy
would ask me to go get coffee.
Those days, because
he just said,
black woman, she'd
be lucky to be
an assistant at a studio,
much less an executive.
And what I realized is that
I internalized a lot of that.
Because it doesn't just go away.
You just suck it up, you just
put it down and say, look I
have a higher purpose here.
When I became the
first black woman
to have a producing
deal at a studio,
that was really important to me.
Not in and of itself, but just
because it was a sign for me
that the mission was working.
But I have to tell you, a few
years ago I was ready to quit.
It was that period of time where
Hollywood was not even thinking
about making movies about
women or people of color.
And obviously, I've done a
little bit of everything,
but that's my sweet spot.
That's the mission
that I started with,
and that was a real
motivation for me.
And I would go into
people's offices
and their eyes would glaze over.
They just weren't interested.
And then you start
throwing stuff up
against the wall
that doesn't really
mean anything to
you in here, which
is where I live as a filmmaker.
And it wasn't sticking, because
it just wasn't, you know.
And honestly, I said to
myself, well, maybe I'm done.
Maybe I have served my purpose.
And I started looking at
maybe I'd take this and go
to Wall Street.
So I started looking
around, because I
was like, I don't want
to live like this,
not feeling fulfilled
and satisfied.
And then honestly, Harriet,
which took me six years,
but started gaining momentum.
And in doing
Harriet, I remembered
why I wanted to make movies.
DEVON FRANKLIN: Nice.
DEBRA MARTIN CHASE:
And thank God, I just
lasted til the tide changed.
And all of a sudden,
because we still
have such a long
way to go, but this
is the best that it's been.
In terms of recognizing
the value of black product
and talent, since I've
been in the business,
and in a real way.
And not black, just
multicultural talent.
From Crazy Rich Asians to
Black Panther and whatever.
So I'm happy I stayed.
I'm--
DEVON FRANKLIN: So are we.
DEBRA MARTIN CHASE:
We're all benefiting.
FRANKLIN LEONARD:
I was going to say,
I'm happy you stayed too Debra.
I don't know if I could have
handled you leaving either.
DEVON FRANKLIN: Lord of mercy.
I don't know.
I don't know if any of us
could have dealt with that.
DEBRA MARTIN CHASE:
Seriously, I had
one foot way out of the door.
DEVON FRANKLIN: Wow.
PHILLIP SUN: [INAUDIBLE]
DEVON FRANKLIN:
But it's a blessing
that you saw that you had to
be here and you persevered.
And obviously
Harriet was amazing,
and all the things you're
doing in film and television
are incredible.
I know our time
is getting short,
but Phil I want
you just to touch
on this quickly if you could.
How do you handle frustration?
PHILLIP SUN: I piggyback
a bit on Franklin.
Definitely exercise.
But it comes down to, my
life changed nine months ago
when I had my son.
As you become a
parent, you realize
that it's not about you,
and it's about legacy.
He's half Chinese, half Jewish.
If he grows up anything
like me, in the environments
that I grew up in, he'll
be seen as different.
He'll be treated as such.
And that doesn't
sit well with me.
So it's more of
a, how am I going
to do my part to
change this world,
this industry this world?
So that he feels like he
belongs, because he does.
And more alongside of that is
the future of the industry.
If I get frustrated
and I quit, then it's
not going to get any better
for the Asian kid, black kid,
woman who's coming up the ranks.
If they can't look up
and see someone did it.
So Frank and I have had
this conversation before.
Maybe it's our duty
in our lifetime
to take this on, and
push the ball forward.
And Deb certainly has
done it, for all of us.
And we will continue to push it.
But the alternative is
not acceptable to me,
which is quitting.
The alternative is
to allow the system
to beat me, which is
not going to happen.
And then I look at my
son, my family, and then
the future generation
of executives,
specifically in representation
for me, and there is no quit.
Because you've got to
make sure that they
can stand on our shoulders.
And keep going.
DEVON FRANKLIN: Devon, you
should answer that question.
PHILLIP SUN: Yeah dude.
DEBRA MARTIN CHASE: With all
that you've accomplished.
You're a governor of the
Motion Picture Academy.
We weren't even getting in
the door a few years ago
to be a member.
DEVON FRANKLIN: Well
thank you, Debra.
This is why you are who you are.
Well I'll answer briefly,
and tie it into our wrap up.
I deal with frustration.
My antidote for
frustration is faith.
There have been times, when
I was an executive, man
I'd be in my office crying.
Because I'm like,
there's got to be more.
I don't understand.
I'm playing by the rules,
but the score is different.
And I don't understand.
I don't know what's going on.
I have these dreams.
I have these hopes.
I'm getting in early,
I'm staying late.
But where's the progress?
And so, in those
darkest moments,
and because we care
so much, I know
I'm not exclusive in that
regard, we internalize.
So when things aren't
necessarily going right for us
in this business, things aren't
initially going right for us
personally.
And so for me, I
would internalize.
And I've learned to
separate the two,
but at the time, especially,
when I was the most frustrated,
I was tethering the two.
My value with my
progress in the business.
And I was looking in
the mirror and not
liking who looked back at me.
Questioning, wondering,
doubting, being insecure.
And so I had to have faith.
I had to say, OK, I know
God has given me a vision.
I have to rely on that vision.
The same way we go
to the movie theater
and we see the trailer for
a movie that we want to see,
I had to keep closing
my eyes and seeing
the trailer of the
movie of my life play
on the screen in my mind.
And that honestly is what has
helped me navigate frustration,
because I go on the inside.
I listen, and I see.
And I say, oh OK,
I can see that.
And that gives me enough energy
and strength to get back up
and fight and get
back in the game
and have conversations
and push and press.
And to Phil's point, not quit.
And so that that's how I've
dealt with frustration,
and that's how I continue to
deal with it, through faith.
And then speaking
of faith, for those
who have been watching
these Academy dialogues,
I really think they should
really be called game changers.
Because every person on
here is a game changer.
I just want to highlight, when
you look at Franklin Leonard.
There was the black list.
There was no one who had
done the black list before.
Here he is as an executive
for Will and James Lassiter,
and had this idea, why don't
I get some of my friends
to rate the scripts
they've been reading?
And out of that one idea
the industry changed.
Debra Martin Chase came to
Hollywood from Harvard Law,
has blazed a trail not only for
women, but for people of color
in making the biggest
movies and now television
shows the industry
has ever seen.
But there was a moment, as she
mentioned, she wanted to quit.
But she said I've
got to keep going.
And as a result,
others can look to her
and see that it's possible.
Phil Sun, just
moments ago, was in,
working for one of the
biggest agencies in Hollywood.
But something in him
said, there's more.
And he took the risk,
stepping out and starting M88.
And now changing the game.
If you are watching this,
the game can be changed.
That is the takeaway.
The system needs changing.
It can be changed.
And the only way to get it done
is for us to have the will.
I've said it before
and I'll say it again.
President John F Kennedy,
when he was in the space race,
and he's trying to
get to the moon.
How do we do it?
His chief engineer
said, all we have
to do is have the will to do it.
I challenge you, if you're
listening to this conversation,
have the will to make
change wherever you may be
and wherever you may sit.
You've been watching
Academy Dialogues.
Thank you so much for
tuning in, and make
sure you stay tuned
because there's
a whole lot more of these
conversations coming to you.